god
[Music]
hey everyone it is jesse and today i'm
going to be testing out five famous
celebrity fried chicken recipes to see
which one is actually the best on
today's lineup i have recipes from snoop
dogg david chang guy fieri katie labelle
and gordon ramsay i measured out all the
ingredients exactly as recipe stated and
i got three of my friends to taste them
in a blind taste test so which celebrity
has the best fried chicken let's get
frying first up is snoop dogg he starts
by making a brine by combining sugar
salt bay leaf red pepper flakes and
orange peel in a pot of simmering water
let that all dissolve cool it off and
pour it over the chicken wrap it up and
let it sit overnight the next day you're
going to take them out and dry them off
with a paper towel so they're nice and
dry
bring that over and in one bowl you're
gonna combine flour cornmeal potato
chips garlic powder cayenne baking
powder black pepper and salt mix that
all up and in the other bowl you're
gonna add some cold buttermilk take each
piece of chicken put in the buttermilk
first then the dry mixture and do that
with all the remaining chicken
bring it over to a fryer
fry until it's nice and crispy
transfer to a wrap
and garnish the top with a bit of salt
there you have it snoop dogg's potato
chip fried chicken okay it kind of looks
like kfc chicken i'm liking the color on
this guy it seems very flaky which is
good
right that means it's crunchy crispy oh
it's real crispy can you hear that oh
oh yeah
this is good but it is really good the
whole bite is delicious like even on the
inside because sometimes what happens is
that with the fried chicken is it'll be
seasoned nicely on the outside but when
you bite into it it doesn't taste like
anything but this is really nice this
tastes similar to kfc chicken it's like
elevated kfc the batter from the outside
it looks like it but the moment you bite
into it it's like whoa next up is david
chang this one is based on a youtube
video not a written recipe so we tried
our best so don't add us in the comments
he starts by making a brine with 50
sugar and 50 salt i stir that all up so
it's nice and dissolved added the
chicken wrapped it up and put it in the
fridge overnight to brine the next day
you're going to take instant ramen
packets and pulverize it in a food
processor and turn it into a flour kind
of as a texture of almond meal
take that transfer it into a bowl and
season both buttermilk and that flour
mixture with the packets that come with
the instant ramen you're going to take
each piece of chicken dip it in
buttermilk first then dip it in the
pulverized instant ramen and you're
going to do that with all of the chicken
take those
dunk them into a preheated fryer and
gently fry them until they're nice and
golden and crisp
once you take them out transfer them to
a rack and season the tops them with a
little bit more of that seasoning packet
that comes with the soup and there you
have it david chang's ramen fried
chicken this looks really cool this
bread crumbing looks a little bit
different than what i've been used to
this looks like
corn it's not rice is it this is ramen
right i love this i think this is super
creative
i like it that's interesting it's got
more texture to it on the outside you
know when you get like rice krispies it
almost feels like that texture of rice
krispies on the outside so you get that
extra crunch the sad thing is that there
are bits here where you see like it
didn't really cling on to it the way
it's supposed to it's still a pretty
good piece of fried chicken flavors on
the money is seasoned all the way
through from the outside to the inside
pretty good piece up next is guy fairy
he starts by making brine by combining
buttermilk pickle juice
hot sauce
dill granulated garlic onion powder salt
pepper in a bowl
and whisking it all together add your
chicken
you're gonna let that sit for two to
four hours so i wrapped it up and i put
it away in the meantime you're going to
make dill salt which is dill salt and
pepper mix all together and set that
aside for later once the chicken is
brined bring it back your combine flour
cornmeal granulated garlic smoked
paprika mustard powder onion powder and
black pepper in a large mixing bowl
whisk that all up and you're going to
take one piece of chicken at a time and
coat it in that flour do this with all
the remaining chicken and you let them
all sit for about 20 to 30 minutes at
room temperature so the breading sets up
bring those into a preheated fryer and
fry them in 350 degree oil until golden
crispy and cooked through
transfer those onto a wire rack and
you're gonna sprinkle the tops with
prepared dill salt that you made
bam and there you have it guy fairies
fried chicken with dill salt wow we got
some green bits in there that's nice do
you see this there's like green on it
that's cute a little less crunchy but
still good we take a bite into it see
what we got
this has a weird taste but in like a
good way definitely a little bit less
seasoning on this one or at least a
little less flavor it didn't penetrate
all the way through to the bone is there
dill on this i like this i think that
like gave it a little
zing that's pretty good i gotta say this
one to me is pretty
normal next up is my queen patti labelle
she starts by generously seasoning
chicken with seasoning salt black pepper
and cayenne and yeah i went heavy
because i've seen the comments on the
other videos and i do not want to be a
victim of those comments
you're going to get a bag fill it with
flour and put chicken in it a few pieces
at a time and shake them up to coat them
do this with all the remaining chicken
take the chicken and we're gonna shallow
frying
patty only uses one quart of vegetable
oil so you're gonna have to flip them a
few times a bit different than the other
recipes
cook them until they're nice and golden
and crisp
transfer them to a paper towel to drain
and there you have it patti labelle's
famous fried chicken okay this looks
like a home style pizza chicken this
one's really pretty
oh no
[Music]
that was juicy we managed to retain some
some juice in here which is really nice
i like the seasoning on it it's pretty
good this one's alright it needs hot
sauce this is another recipe that's
based on a youtube video gordon ramsay
starts off by soaking chicken in
buttermilk to that he adds shallots
garlic and onion the video looks like he
might have put some herbs in it but he
didn't call for it so i didn't use him i
wrapped this up i stuck in the fridge
overnight the next day he seasons flour
with salt cayenne and pepper mixes that
together gordon ramsay double dredges
the chicken this means he first puts it
in the flour then back into the
buttermilk and back into the flour one
more time so it gives it kind of an
extra thick crispier coating he does
this with all the chicken and he
transfers it to a preheated bread
he takes each piece of chicken dips it
into a 325 degree fryer and fries it
until it's nice and crispy and golden
when he takes them out he sprinkles the
top with a little bit of salt and he
says if it's not fully cooked you can
transfer them to the oven for a few more
minutes just until they're done cooking
and there you go gordon ramsay's fried
chicken
all right this one's real crispy is that
all breaded let me just take a bite and
see what the flavor's looking like
in terms of flavor really not my
favorite this literally tastes like dry
turkey on thanksgiving day
no gravy i can't really taste too much
in the batter can't really taste too
much in the meat this one doesn't have
any taste when it comes to flavors i
like power like a lot of like you know
stuff that sticks out at you nothing in
general really sticks out of me with in
terms of this particular piece of
chicken pretty plain i gotta say
so which celebrity has the best fried
chicken let's find out
out of these five fried chickens that i
tried today i think i'm gonna have to go
with three three had a different taste
but i think it was because of the dill
and that put it to the top what you see
that makes sense guy fairy's like bomb
hello out of the five different types of
fried chicken that i tried today
my favorite one has to be
number one it was packed with flavor the
skin was super nice it was really juicy
and from the outside to inside the
flavor penetrated all the way through
which is something i'm always looking
for when it comes to fried chicken clear
winner in my eyes snoop dogg oh
i knew my guy would hook up some popping
chicken man so out of these five fried
chicken celebrity recipes i think my
winner is number one it was just like
the first bite
bit into it and i was like
mine blue who was it are you serious wow
that's awesome so there you have it
snoop dogg has the best fried chicken
which recipe should we try next let us
know in the comments
[Music]